[Music]
in a world obsessed with Trump
alternative facts have not add a great
press but it's a century and more since
Nietzsche claimed there are no facts
only interpretations and 50 years since
Thomas Kuhn argued that facts were
theory dependent so is an insistence on
the facts the prejudice of believers in
their particular truth do we have to
give up the idea that facts decide the
matter or a facts essential to science
and progress without them only chaos
reigns I want to add introduce my three
speakers or mayor immediate right and
there's no political implications about
this at all is Barry Bonds as a
sociologist and co-founder of the
influential strong program and approach
to the sociology of scientific knowledge
described by inheritor such as Bruno
Latour as unparalleled in its importance
for the field is an advocate at the post
kuhnian approach to scientific knowledge
and his interest in the distinction
between objective facts and into
subjective agreement you can ask him
what any of those words mean at a later
stage
am i extreme left if that's the right
word is John Ellis who's a Maxwell Prize
winning theoretical physicist he's made
important contributions in many fields
who inquire including particle physics
astrophysics and cosmology Jana I've got
it wrong again already have there no
sorry she's an award-winning writer at
The Guardian Huffington Post London
Review of Books immense many others her
latest book a field guide to reality
recognizes the importance of philosophy
and believes that philosophy should be
accessible to everyone and I'm gonna
start with you Joanna whether you think
that an insistence upon facts is in the
sense a religious position adopted by
true believers so there's a line in a
novel by Dorothy L Sayers which I'll
begin with she writes facts are like
cows
if you look them hard in the face for
long enough they generally run away and
so I want to look at the term even just
this little word fact hard in the face
and as soon as we do we see like so many
words it's full of ambiguities and
echoes and even contradictions
there's the understanding that we might
initially have of objective reality the
actual objective truth the facts but
then there's also a meaning from the
anglo-french feats and fay jfet this
sense that something's happened
somebody's done something and this
suggests a subjective reality and this
is really important to the debate
because it's incredibly difficult to
disentangle an objective truth there's
always someone within it there's someone
observing it there's someone looking at
it someone experiencing what's going on
so the combination of elements in this
word fact I think are really important
to the debate and if we were objective
and trans-temporal that we could stand
aloft we could wave ourselves above this
reality that we're all in and look
across time and space then it might not
really help because we'd find that
through the ages many things have been
hailed one moment as a fact and then
hailed as a fiction the next so if we
alighted in the 1840s for example we'd
find that germ theory was definitely not
a fact it was a fiction which was really
exome to poor Ignatz Semmelweis he was
trying to propound it as a serious and
factual theory the poor man was told he
was mad which he wasn't but then
actually he got so insanely angry about
being constantly told he was mad when he
wasn't that he went mad and so he ended
up dying in an asylum which is very sad
fact me more though if he went off again
on your celestial vehicle and you came
back to the 1880s you'd find that germ
theory is a fact and Louie Pasteur who's
the progenitor now is having a much
nicer time and he's being awarded the
Legion of Honour and generally being
hailed as a great Pro pounder of effect
and this happens with so many theories
with the ether which as john can tell
you is a fact one minute of fiction the
next and I sort of adjusted fact again
and then a fiction with ideas of women
not having enough strength to run long
distances which was a stencil
fact throughout the whole of the modern
Olympics until finally in 1988 they were
given parity and allowed to run the
marathon and that so-called fact became
a fiction
so I'd say as we continue in our quest
for knowledge which is so important
there is this question of when is a fact
a future fiction and when is a fiction a
future fact and I think we should look
facts in the face in this quest and we
should also remember maybe Chuck
Palahniuk the novelist his argument that
you can build an entire wall with facts
and obscure reality in doing so Thanks
it's cool enough in here to want to get
your hands clapping Barry
same question to you if you would yeah
well in the debate I'm going to urge
caution in the face of facts whether
pressed on you as verbal assertions were
pointed out you as features of the world
but first of all that's this question to
reflect on about them about believers
and and the questions too difficult for
me so I've decided to answer another one
oh no you get home you get contributors
like this my question is why would
believers speak of facts at all and they
do so in my view right we need to
sustain their beliefs as knowledge and
they've got that need because shared
knowledge is necessary for living with
other people as human beings always do
everywhere and for coordinating the
actions of those people and it's this
that makes how do you know a more
important and urgent question than why
do you believe even if you're a believer
yourself that's the more important
question how do you know now a brief
history of the world will fill this out
and you've got about a minute and a half
that's great our adapter in ancient
times priests look to Authority to
sustain belief and they invoke the
epistemic authority of sacred texts or
they
five rulers in enlightened Europe
philosophers rejected faith in authority
and turned to reason instead use of
reason could lead us all to a single
truth so can'tcan't told us they soon
became clear that the inner voice of
reason spoke differently to different
people and could pull them apart as
easily as bring them together well
moving on a century or so when groups of
paid professionals called scientists
first emerged in the following century
and competed for positions in the
hierarchy of occupations they challenged
rationalists to turn away from sterile
internally directed reflection open
their eyes and look around everyone has
access to the world beyond the eyeball
was their view of things and we can all
get together if we look at that world
and hope to agree on what the facts are
preferably the facts known to scientists
themselves by direct experience but
never mind
you check things against facts that way
and identify what you've checked as
facts themselves well since that times
facts have been widely cited as the
epistemic basis of empirical knowledge
although the credibility of this
misconceived view is currently in
decline not least within the sciences
themselves from physics to biology
scientists now increasingly rely on
models and on statistical methods as the
foundations of their ways of knowing and
that means they no longer find it
necessary to talk of facts all truths
and
very cunning of me to leave the only
real scientist on the panel to the last
not least I assume to defend facts yeah
I am afraid I'm going to defend facts
objective facts not subjective facts not
sociological constructions not ways to
keep no societies on the same page so
now you hold up an apple it falls that's
that's a fact if you do a particular
experiment at the Large Hadron Collider
you find something that's a fact
there's a question of interpretation
whether that's really a Higgs boson or
something else that's still being
debated but you do define something
there is an objective fact there so I'm
sorry to be so sort of old-fashioned and
sort of 19th century that's very
charming I may look like I come from the
19th century but actually not quite so
of course no my anachronistic defense of
the existence of objective objective
facts has to accept the fact that they
have a very limited range of
applicability for more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you